i'm dave i run a surfboard repair shop
in la and today i'm going to run you
through how to restore a vintage dewy
weber surfboard
to start i clean the board using a razor
blade and acetone
you don't want to use a brand new razor
blade just because they're so sharp
sometimes they will scratch the surface
of the board underneath the wax when
you're getting that off and cleaning it
up
from what i can tell from this board i
think it was probably made in the 1960s
when restoring a vintage board it's
definitely important to
take note of any original markings which
include a signature by the shaper any
kind of logos from when it was
originally made you want to keep all
that intact
because it definitely affects the
authenticity of the surfboard
[Music]
the delamination occurs when heat or
stress or anything else separates the
fiberglass from the foam core of the
surfboard technique for delaminations
it's pretty easy all kind of knock on
the board
if it sounds like you're hitting a
countertop that's usually a good sound
it sounds kind of like a dual thud or
like cardboard that's a sure sign that
it's de-animated if the fiberglass isn't
adhered well to the foam underneath
there's a lot of flexing happening if
you let's say falling away or drop in
late on the wave and your feet land
where a delamination is you're much more
likely to snap the board in half
next i'll check the board for dings
dings are any any crack in the
fiberglass of the surfboard i determine
what tool i'm going to use based on the
severity of the ding
but i generally start with any kind of
abrasive or sanding tool usually a
grinding disc or some kind of sandpaper
fourth step is
generally filling any dings that are
dented all the way into the foam of the
surfboard
the filled dings i use q cell and
laminating resin i generally prefer to
mix a lot of q gel into the resin and
get it almost consistency of peanut
butter or thicker the only dings that
don't require filling is where the
integrity of the shape
or the outline of the surfboard isn't
changed
so this board looks like it had been
previously repaired someone attempted to
repair this delamination before that's
what all these spots are from the top of
the board and i pulled that flap up all
that resin pulled out of the foam but it
stayed adhered to
the flap of fiberglass
i'm removing these hanging pieces of
resin because uh i'm using filler on the
board and that's going to build those
holes so it won't fit back in
i'm mixing up resin and hue cells this
is forming a kind of paste and when it
cures it forms a chemical bond between
that flap of fiberglass and foam core of
the surfboard so i'm applying this in
between those two layers
[Music]
i'm i'm kind of getting rid of any of uh
the foam that's stuck to this panel of
fiberglass and what that's going to do
is enable that fiberglass to lay uh more
flush against the foam pore of the
support
so right here i'm using egg crate foam
i'm putting that on the board because
the next step we're going to lay some
wood over the top of the surfboard and
then use clamps to uh to fasten that
duct and that adheres this flap back to
the surface of the phone
[Music]
what i'm doing now is sanding down some
of this resin that squeezed through the
cracks when i clamped the flap down
a filler that i used isn't necessarily
waterproof it's actually porous and so
fiberglass and resin once applied to the
fiberglass creates a waterproof barrier
this goes over your filler in this case
we're not going to do fiberglass over
the entire top of the board because that
would make it too heavy
it generally takes between one and three
hours for your resin to cure whether
it's a hot coat or lamination you can
speed it up by adding more resin but
you're gonna get not a very good cure so
you gotta stick to the ratios
six step sanding or feathering the edges
of that fiberglass back down into the
regular board
the purpose of feathering your
fiberglass patches is aesthetic as well
as functional if you have a hard square
patch that could cause or to fracture
along that flat edge if it's gliding
after that would be applying your hot
coat resin as some people call it a hot
coat is laminating resin mixed with a
chemical additive called surfacing agent
and what that is is wax it rises to the
top of the resin as it sets and it
allows you to stand at the same paper on
the top of the board the damage is so
extensive that i'm just going to do one
hot coat over the entire surfboard
[Music]
on the bottom the damage looks a lot
less extensive so i'm just going to
focus on the specific areas that need
attention rather than spending the time
doing the entire bottom of the board
the eighth step is
sanding those areas that you were
working on
i've used a 60 grit sanding disc that's
the lowest or most coarse sandpaper i
use when i'm grinding my lamination
after doing my hot coat i'm actually
doing the fine sanding start with 120
grit move to 220
350.
start wet sanding at 400 then up to 600
and then
generally you'd be done at 600 for a
sanded finish
but if you're doing a polished finish
like this you go from 600 to 800
to 1200 this board took me about three
hours to sand that's a pretty standard
amount of time for a job like this
skipping grits would save time but you
would not come out with a good finish
it's important to spend the time on each
grit if you want your board to come out
looking for steam
it's time to polish the board so you
grab your polishing compound and a
buffing wheel and polish the board up
polishing the board it's purely
aesthetic that's how you're going to get
that mirror finish on surfboard
dewey weber was one of the most famous
uh and influential surfboard shapers of
his time when i first got the board i
paid around 300 for it
[Music]
in its restored condition i would
estimate this board's worth somewhere
around a thousand dollars
this restoration was
super satisfying and fun to work on i'm
really excited to get this board back
out and go surf
now the board is fixed it'll last a
lifetime if taken care of correctly
[Music]